hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
July 31st
2020 tree
Jesus Christ where's the summer going
I feel like every other year I'll say to
myself in may now all right
summer's coming
make sure you take it in and then every
other year I don't and then all of a
sudden it's almost [__] August
um and I even had a bottle since James
yet dude
I've been enjoying a little time off uh
with the family back east
the big thing when you go back East is
oh I can't eat all this [__] Italian
food you know all the stuff that I miss
all the [__] pizza and the bread and
all the [__] that they can't make out
now it's got It's the air
it's the water
you know what there's some guys from
Brooklyn they just moved out here they
flew the water from Brooklyn out it
still stinks
still stinks I don't know what it is
they um
they can make really good pizza they
can't make great pizza out there and
they can make really good pasta with it
it's just I don't know what it is
it's just not the same I remember doing
a gig a long time ago uh
Count Basie Theory Theory theater
out in uh Red Bank New Jersey and I was
I forget where I was going next I just
randomly
stopped in some little strip mall
and they had a little store there they
were making like pasta by hand and all
some of the best [__] I've ever had in
my life
just random didn't have to know anybody
just saw the Italian flag stopped and it
was [__] unbelievable so
um
we're back here uh
for a few days
the family and all of that have been
getting caught up on my Boston Red Sox
dude
how about Tristan uh Cassis is that all
you say is hitting the cover off the
ball he's been crushing it
Justin Turner's been killing it got that
Duran guy flying around on the bases
I mean I know we lost the last two games
in uh
overtime job and uh Extra Innings
but uh they're still they're a fun team
to watch and uh I'm just like that guy
at first base is panning out
we always have some [__] like nine
foot guy
playing for the Red Sox
you know halfway decent in the field
but can hit a curveball or an off-speed
pitch but everybody's always like I'll
tell you if he ever gets a hold of one
I know dude but the [__] guy the body
on the guy if he ever gets a [__]
older one dude he's gonna [__] damage
and it never happens
well now it's happening
um
so I've enjoying that we're playing
Seattle to Seattle Mariners in the
[__] Kingdome
Key Arena they knocked them all down
what's the name what are they Edison
field
should be Tesla Fields shouldn't it
didn't Edison steal everything from
Tesla the the actual Tesla
not not the laminated face nerd that
wants to have a cage match
with that calculus major
is that gonna I heard the other I heard
the Facebook guy actually does mixed
martial arts which means he could
[__] throw me around the room I
wonder what the other guy did they I
don't know what happened
you know it's really [__] nuts what
people would do when it comes to money
you know unless they're in business
together and they were going to do some
Jake Paul [__]
that's I said that before that should be
the winner the winner fights Jake Paul
for for the title uh in the Jake Paul
boxing Association
the JP ibf
um
yeah it's really just been uh
seeing how crazy hot it's been this year
and all that type of stuff and then you
just I'm watching like the media and
they go
what did they call like cities that are
like ungodly hot now they're calling
them something cities
charred cities hot cities or whatever
but they're not going to talk about how
the [__] we ended up here
because they're not going to [__] with
their money and it's just like at some
point you're going to be like guys what
are you protecting here
there's going to be nothing left the
direction we're going I want to get all
[__] doomsday here but Jesus Christ
they just [__] talk around the whole
thing
they don't say that since 1959 1950
[__] nine scientists are going hey
man
the way we're living yeah it's gonna do
this to the planet they're like that
I'll be dead by then
give me another [__] uh lobster roll
and a couple of [__] to [__] lick
my balls while I eat it
[Laughter]
I always wondered about people like that
that are like just totally into their
own pleasure regardless of how many
people that they hurt
right which I guess we've all been
guilty of that
you know [__]
going into the fridge late at night
eating the last slice of something
having the last few cookies
got the crumbs in the side of your face
and your wife's like
did you eat that peanut butter cookie
and you're like whoa
and you get a feign like you're not
selfish oh
did you want that
that's when you just get the side glance
and they walk out of the [__] room
um so anyway I'm on vacation here
with the family and uh
you know I don't have access to a gym so
I've been doing so well over the last
month
but uh
I do have access down the road they rent
some bicycles or whatever so I'm gonna
ride a bike like a [__] European guy
which is good because I'm trying to get
into Euro shape
all right from for my fellow Americans
listening to this podcast I try to get
myself in really good shape before I go
to Europe just to shut those [__]
[__] up you know because they're always
talking about how out of shape Americans
are and everything right and then you go
over there
you know and they think somehow they eat
fish and chips out of a [__] old
newspaper every day and they're gonna
have a body of an Adonis
um
but they are in uh
they are in better shape they just have
better food than we do so
um if a European come on over here I'm
sure the dollar is nice and weak
right
come over here you [__] eat some of
our food you bulk up
and you go back to the pub and you face
your high school bully
you [__] lean on them with all those
trans fats you're carrying around your
[__]
your testicles and your uh your [__]
man tits there whatever your testicles
that's what I call them when you [__]
love handles
uh
the [__] was I just going to talk about
something in that reminded me of
something I was like you know what I
should talk about that
that is what I should talk about
you know it just it left me
um but anyway I'm gonna uh
make sure I just keep eating the salads
with the protein and all of that stuff
um what the [__] is this stop texting me
how dare you text me when I'm in the
middle of my podcast
um yeah so I got I got that gig coming
up I got Halifax coming up I got
Springfield Massachusetts coming up
so my big thing is that I'm just gonna I
landed and I had some I had a salad
it's a little bit of chicken in it feta
cheese
you know but I I didn't uh I didn't work
out yesterday so
it's [__] you know every time every
time I start to get in shape oh Bill
what are you gonna do now how are you
gonna [__] whine about your life
boohoo you're so busy when your whole
business is on [__] strike I do love
how [__] heartless some people are
you know I've seen that there was a guy
that writes for that show the bear which
is a massive massive hit and the writing
is incredible on it he writes on the
show he has a gig writing for a hit TV
show and he's living below the poverty
line right so most people were
empathetic somebody writes uh get
another job
blaming him right he's working 17-hour
[__] days 14 hour days or whatever in
the right is Roman and get another
[__] job and then somebody goes why
don't you have the actors pay him
you know because they look at actors
going you know thinking they're all
making a zillion dollars you know
um
and they like know their names that's
the genius
of being the money behind the money is
nobody knows your [__] name telling
the ad that the actors should pay the
[__] writer is like you know they're
underpaying the guy you know unloading
trucks at Home Depot and then the
manager of Home Depot should pay the guy
not the people that own Home Depot and
own the [__] building
hey you're underpaying that quarterback
the uh cornerback the quarterback should
pay him
well what about the [__] owner
ah the quarterback's making too much
money what does the owner make I have no
idea I don't even know what his [__]
name is exactly
um and all the guy was asking for was
just a [__] middle class
living
so
um that is kind of the genius of this
whole
[__] rat race is it causes you to
turn
on uh the wrong person I feel
so I'm for the workers here
I'm not for these [__]
I mean the only time you ever know like
a CEO's name is when he takes it to such
a ridiculous level such like a spinal
tap ridiculous level of greed that he
[__] ends up on uh that show American
Greed
that guy hit a 13 000
umbrella stand
it's funny is when they're stealing from
the company they end up failing guilty
you know in the back of their head so
then they uh
they start throwing these lavish parties
and they invite their co-workers
and it somehow appeases their guilt yeah
I stole the money but I you know I I
threw a party and I invited my
co-workers so I'm kind of like Robin
Hood right
and then eventually the feds show up
and then they go to jail
and I always pick their picture their
jail
is like a tennis club
you know that just has like modest
sort of quarters or something
I wonder what the number one like
[__]
weapon is in a white-collar prison like
it's like a letter opener
a sharpened money clip
uh he smuggled it into his [__] ass
this Fanny package you're probably
allowed to have one
um
I know you guys if you guys want to
submit some [__] jokes for that
makes me miss the David Letterman show
tonight here in my hand I have the top
10 list
the top 10 weapons in a white-collar
prison
words
um all right
plowing ahead here that reminded me of
uh
I don't know what the hell I was
watching but that that whole [__] you
know speaking of traveling and all of
that [__] you remember that was another
show [__] arrested abroad
which I swear to God you got halfway
through one
episode is he's like I don't even go
into Rhode Island I am not leaving
you know when you leave your tribe
like you're an American you live in
America then all of a sudden you go
somewhere else
and you do some dumb [__] right and you
get your dumb ass caught doing the dumb
[__] and then what you what do you do
you you [__] try to reach out to your
local senator
like hey man you know I'm on your team
and they're like keeping me over here
man like that's not cool right and then
you realize
you know your value
when all of a sudden you realize you've
been left unprotected
in your own country is fine with you
testing the free agent Market in
different prisons around the globe
that's when you just like oh no
I was believing all that [__] they said
every four years when I actually pay
attention to politics
when they [__] uh when when they they
gas up Joe's six-pack
yeah he puts his pants on one leg at a
time Jay gets cancer from the local
[__] area where they were testing uh
Atomic weapons back in the 50s and 60s
and uh now we're not going to help him
out but once a year we give them a shout
out let me give them a shout out and we
talk about how he puts his pants on
and then after that when uh you know he
can't get a [__] job or he's uh you
know lost the limb
fighting for this country
uh you know
then we don't know him but once every
four years
maybe the beginning of a football game
you know we'll parade them out
there he is Joe's six-pack
he only hit his wife once
um that was the surprise ending there
right I was I was sitting there going
you got to remember these guys
that was just my way of saying aren't we
all just a little bit flawed
um
somebody gave oh what's his face uh
Brian Holtzman gave me this book he's
going to be on my podcast uh he gave me
this book um
what the [__] killers of the the
something Moon
killers of the leaf moon or something
like that it's just another one of these
[__] stories that they you know they
just don't tell you about
when you're coming up in uh grade school
it's always like okay a bunch of white
people came over here with buckles on
their shoes because they were getting
away from religious persecution which
now is kind of [__] hilarious to me
you know you like [__]
gonna persecute me because I'm going to
church it's like I I all right I won't
go
I don't have a problem with that
let me twist my [__] arm hey you know
what I'd go to church but there's too
much persecution out there
oh my God that's not what religious
persecution is
um
you know religious persecution is making
somebody go to church every Sunday
remember that your parents making you
get up oh you just have that [__]
feeling in your stomach you put on that
itchy sweater
you go down there and there'd be that
[__] old guy up there and he would
just be going like it would always go
really fast up to and this is the word
of the Lord and people that thanks be to
God
and then the guy break into his homily
you know
I live alone in the rectory
drink a lot of wine that hasn't been
blessed
every once in a while I volunteer for
some sort of activity with little boys
but we're not going to talk about that
and he would just go on and on
and on and on and you would just be
sitting there wrap it up just [__]
wrap it up
Fabulous Thunderbirds wrap it up I'll
take it right
and finally
this old unmarried [__] poor bastard
with no fly on his pants
you know like you couldn't shimmy him
down if he got a hooker right
I'd love to have uh
illegal sex with you but I just can't
get these damn things off
oh well you see what they do is they sew
them onto you
what was your name Porsche oh Impala
sorry Impala what they do is they
[__]
they sew them around your hips and then
you just keep eating the body of Christ
and each week you get a little fatter
and then that's it
it's like a chastity belt for a guy
those black pre-slacks
rayon you know it's funny the same pants
that priests wear
is the same one that all real estate
agents wore when I was growing up sorted
the Nancy Reagan power suit I thought
that was fitting because you know
both groups of people were [__] you
right oh Jesus bill
was I talking about this on stage or was
I talking on my podcast
I said because the
I was talking about how because porn is
free now
and these Abused women can't make any
money
like I feel like they're now all getting
into real estate like judging like what
real estate agents look like now
I mean they look like
horse
at a Ron Burgundy party you know when
they would like you know back in the day
when your hairy chested friend was
coming to town
you know
your job was to Rally up a couple of
[__] and make sure he he had a good
time
make sure he has a good time when he's
out here hunt hunt doll face
okay Daddy all right and they [__] go
out and they'd
ride the guy clinging to his chest hair
whatever happened
to come back if the
if they'll think chest hair at some
point is Gonna Come Back
what about remember that little
toothbrush thing that they had for guys
that you could like manicure your whole
body
so let's say how [__] long does that
take
for the average Greek man or Italian guy
to [__] get ready for work if you're
going to give him he he needs like a
Dust Buster level one right now you get
someone like me
you know
I got the orangutan hair so I mean it
doesn't even show up
you could give me I could use one of
those things
I'm in the land of Martha Stewart right
now she's a Connecticut person right I'm
staying out here in Connecticut I like
Connecticut right
it's got uh it's got everything he could
possibly want here
from you know gang activity to uh
Elite white people in the clan I mean
you just sort of have
you could do like
20 seasons
of behind the scenes in prisons
and America to American Greed
Connecticut's a very interesting State
and I think that that's why they don't
have any time you're in a state that
doesn't have any professional sports
teams I always feel like they're up to
something
you know
like this is where these the super rich
go to hang out
and stuff like that you know
out on out on the uh the Prairies out
there
charred cities
people on fire if you catch on fire
because of this this heat wave what to
do if you catch on fire we're not going
to discuss how we ended up here
what to do when the water that you
wanted to use to brush your teeth starts
boiling before it gets to your mouth
here's the five things that you can do
to not scald your gums
today we have
anti-scalding your gum expert
Tammy [__] what's her [__] right
and she's going to sit here with her
priests [__] real estate slacks on and
she's going to let us know how in 2027
you go about brushing your teeth
you know there's a lot of people are
starting to say that the incredible Rays
rise in halitosis
is actually not caused by boiling water
that you can't the water that you can't
get to your mouth before it starts
boiling it's actually the cause of
global warming it's the bad breath
that is the new now of course Liberals
are calling this misinformation
conservatives are calling this socialism
but I'm still making 400 Grand a week to
read this [__] to you
and I have enough money to have my own
fire department
that will spray foam
on top of my house when it ignites
and on to make as I roll around in the
yacht what am I talking about I don't
know
I have no idea I'm [__] getting used
to the the time change out here my son
got up at [__] still six in the
morning six in the morning doesn't
matter what time zone we're in so it's
just like three o'clock our time
still available
yeah I forgot he doesn't like milk in
his oatmeal
he's like Dad I don't know what no well
no want milk
I don't want milk and I'm like well I
don't have to tell you buddy I can't
take the milk out of it
and he's like okay bye-bye and he just
[__] walks away
um he's a very confident little kid
very confident little kid
um
anyway so I'm going to try to enjoy
myself out here
for you know a couple two three days a
little four day thingamajig here and
then uh then I'm back to the Grind
I'm gonna be back on the road again and
uh like I said
I'm gonna somehow wake up here
I'm gonna ride a bicycle every day I'm
gonna eat salads the green shirt diet
continues I had a fun week flying man
I flew up to Santa Ynez again I've been
racking up the hours and then uh
I flew a buddy of mine up to uh Santa
Barbara
we hung out across from the uh
whatever the [__] the name of that third
theater is up there that I I haven't
played in years
oh God not the Algonquin the Alexander
begins with an a the Alameda
hang on a second let me look this
[__] theater up
Santa
Barbara theater there's two of them
it's like the Gleason
there the Arlington
well there's also an Amphitheater up
there with like Joni Mitchell did her
live albums yeah the Arlington Theater
[Music]
um
I knew when I when both times when I ate
there they said there's a great uh
Mexican restaurant next door both times
they ordered these tacos and they were
delicious
so we went up there we just had the Uber
driver
uh
you know I Googled Bill Burr Santa
Barbara and I found the theater so I
just had him drop us in the vicinity and
I picked the first Mexican place around
there there wasn't anything else it was
absolutely delicious
um
but I had a fun flight up there you I
learned City pads and if the city pads
are all full you land on taxiway Jay
um Juliet
and uh but I got I got close to 11 hours
um
flight time last month and I'm kind of
like was my goal it's like I want to
start getting like 10 hours a month
and do like some longer flights
as opposed to just sort of zipping
around the LA Basin but I we I have the
Garmin 750
Avionics
in the helicopter there and um
I guess I was due for a download so my
instructor downloaded the thing so I'm
flying out there and I looked at
everything looked
basically the same it was just a little
more colorful
I'm gonna go outside God damn it because
this I'm gonna shut off this [__] AC
speaking of
hot cities
hot cities in this city
temperatures 68 degrees what are we
gonna have a [__] snowball fight in
here
I like a nice 71.
that's where I'm at
you know you know what's funny is when
you stay with other people the fatter
your friends are the [__] lower the
AC goes
like that's you know if you're not
someone who likes to step step on a
scale
I think the temperature you put your uh
AC on if you're putting your AC on
at [__]
65 degrees
that's because you have the same sort of
body fat as like a [__] polar bear
oh Christ these cushions are all wet
I wanted to sit outside
you son of a [__]
huh
I'm mad at nature right now
[__] you guys not I'm standing on a
porch right now and I'm looking at a
herd of cows
oh Jesus my son's
getting into it with his mother
confident little kid man I'm telling you
um
listen to the birds dude you don't hear
that out west then they've got birds in
California
oh what that Bird's saying
he's either trying to get laid or he's
making fun of my bald head one or the
other but I'm going to go back inside
here all right let's read some of the
advertising here for this week
um
I ain't doing [__] [__]
for four days how great is that
not doing [__] I'm just gonna [__]
I'm watching the Red Sox that's what I'm
doing it's you know it sucks about the
baseball seasons is right when when the
games really start to matter
football starts
and they got 5 000 [__] sports
channels so they're showing all this
priests can I can I tell you something I
[__] hate preseason football
I [__] hate it it's like for like
five plays they put the starters in and
then it's just a a bunch of I don't know
what usfl play oh Jesus why would you go
off on another I actually like the usfl
but um
I don't know
there's always that friend you got
that's like totally like hardcore
[__] fantasy football and he'll watch
the entire preseason
you know and they love discovering new
I'll tell you man you know our backup
punter
guy's got a [__] Cannon for a leg
I'll tell you it wouldn't surprise me if
he's challenging aristata for a job
that's what you're doing it's the
[__] last month of Summer and you're
[__] sitting here watching people who
aren't going to make the NFL play in the
NFL what is this Make-a-Wish football I
don't want to watch this [__] I want to
see the people that made the team on
week one and I cannot wait for that
first Monday Night Football game I am
I am so [__] amped up
for the Jets versus the bills
I think the AFC East is going to be
amazing because the Dolphins are a good
team the Jets got Aaron Rodgers
all right and then uh
the Bill's got Josh Allen who I swear to
God if you if if you told me he was
claymation I would believe it
there's just something about his [__]
head
it just looks like the kind like the
kind of like back in the day when they
would just draw a little boy he has like
a little boy head
like the All-American boy six-year-old
boy like oh boy oh boy you know raccoon
skin on his head gonna go fly a kite
with this [__] slingshot that's what
his head looks like but somehow he sees
pushing 30.
um I I that is the [__] story that's
the only story that I give a [__] about
in the uh
the NFL and then also I love that no
one's picking the Patriots so for the
first time in 20 years this is like zero
expectations
um
so I'm gonna enjoy that we can be
playing like spoilers but just this
whole idea that the Buffalo Bills are
where this foregone conclusion to win
the division is now over Dolphins gave
him a little bit of rough time
with uh two attackers a quarterback
right and uh technical 40 uh
uh Gossett Jr or something like that and
quarterback but
um that's I think Aaron Rodgers this is
my prediction all right
for someone
who didn't play organized football play
past August of third grade because my
dad saw the concussions that I was going
to get and did and then did the math
with how slow I was and was just like
he's already dumb
what are we doing here right so um
I think the game is in New York City
I say buffalo looks like they're going
to win Aaron Rodgers brings him back
classic comeback
Jets Nation goes absolutely [__]
crazy
the claymation kid meets Aaron Rodgers
in the middle of the field and he nods
he goes all right we'll I'll see you in
a couple of months and then I think the
Bills win it
right and it comes down to the wire and
then hopefully they both make the
playoffs
and kick the [__] out of each other and
have a great game that's that's all I'm
looking for
all right I'm looking for the San Diego
Chargers as an organization to somehow
get their [__] together because I feel
like they have the players
they've never had the GM they've never
had the ownership they've never had the
whole [__] thing going on
all right and I think San Diego
Chargers
fans have waited long enough I like
Justin Herbert and then who else do we
got who else do we got you're buying a
selling Jimmy G
huh
going to uh Vegas I mean I think that's
perfect
I mean there's two places Italians love
live in New Jersey and Las Vegas
so this dude
is right where he needs to be and how
great would it be if the raid is
you know I'm rooting for that division
too I just want to see I just want to
see great football this year
you know yeah what's his face
out in uh Denver
maybe they turning around maybe he just
said well you know one bad year trying
to get it acclimated to the team
he was also building that giant house
right
maybe that was a distraction
we were just going like honey like which
one of these we need to look at tile
samples
for The Grotto
and he's going like oh but I got a game
this week
just it'll only take a few minutes what
okay great what and and then we'll do
the backsplash
the backsplash for the full kitchen Down
By The Grotto
um why do we need a full kitchen down
there
um anyway I still believe
I still believe in the Broncos and then
um
I don't know [__] about it there's
somehow you know what the one division
that I just don't know [__] anything
about is the AFC South
all I know is for some reason the
Indianapolis who's in the Midwest
is in the south
and first in my world it's a lot easier
to confuse the north with the south and
east with West but when you start
confusing the Midwest with the South
like I don't know what the [__] to do
there's always that one Oddball team
it's just hanging off like an appendix
and is in is in the uh
like the Red Wings
I mean technically they're an East Coast
team right they're [__]
uh that's not the example it was always
where was it what the Seattle Seahawks
now they were out in the west that made
sense
there's a couple just weird [__]
teams they would just maybe the LA Kings
the LA Kings being in the Smythe and it
was literally like Edmonton Vancouver
Calgary everything was way the [__] up
in Canada and then they were just out
there by themselves the closest [__]
American team to the LA Kings at one
point was the St Louis Blues
that's how much times have changed
the NHL dude I'll tell you for a while
they could not pick a [__] City
they could not pick a [__] City to
save their life and now they have been
crushing it
um all right I'm all over the map here
Let's do let's do some of the reads here
Let's do let's do some [__]
[__] reads
all right uh policy genius everybody
you know if you have a family like I do
you know how much your loved ones depend
on you in a worst case scenario you
wouldn't want them to worry about money
a good turn your death into a windfall
of cash with policy genius a good life
and give your wife motive
to start putting [__] adding some extra
ingredients into your food a good life
insurance plan can give you peace of
mind that if something happens to you
your family will have a safety net to
cover mortgage payments College costs
are other expenses so they can get back
on their feet and focus on what's most
important her finding a new swinging
dick to buy her some bags and shoes oh
already have coverage through work
employers sponsored life insurance may
not offer enough protection for your
family needs you know it isn't worth
[__]
why would your boss care if you died
once you're dead he has no need for you
he's not going to cover for you you need
policy genius anyway and if it won't
follow you if and it won't follow you if
you leave your job oh your life
insurance that you're paying into with
policy genius well there's a great way
to scam your employers
you have a portion of the check you just
withdraw it every year and it goes into
this Life Insurance Fund right
goes into the Life Insurance Fund but
then if you leave or get fired the money
from your check that was into that
[__] fund does not go with you dude
there's so many [__] scams people we
got to go back to tipping and cash
somebody finally gave me a heads up on
that I was thinking that the other day
when I was at the airport and I bought a
magazine and it said tip and I was
looking at the sad ladies sitting there
at the register I was like I'll give you
a 10 15 tip on a [__] magazine that I
went and picked out myself
and I was thinking afterwards was on the
car I'm like how the [__] does it go to
her a portion of the proceeds do the
rest of it goes to the to the goddamn
people that own that kiosk so
I don't know what I'm saying here with
policy genius you can find life
insurance policies that start at just 25
dollars per month for one million
dollars of coverage
you can pay 25 and get a million dollars
worth of coverage you must be [__]
zero percent body fat
stepping out of an Olympic pool some
options offer coverage in as little as a
week and avoid unnecessary medical exams
we don't need a medical exam I'm sure
you're fine with your Pelican neck
policy genius has licensed award-winning
agents who can help you find the best
fit for your needs no wonder they have
thousands of five star reviews on Google
and trustpilot your loved ones deserve a
financial safety net you deserve a
smarter way to find find and buy it head
to policygenius.com or click the link in
the description to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much you
could save that's
policygenius.com oh look who it is
everybody it's old zip
bread fruit
you know if you're hiring you know that
it's incredibly hard to attract top
talent
and with the current labor market
conditions it's even harder than ever
that's why you wanted that was so
[__] vague that's why you want to get
up you want a partner who gets it
you want zip
[Music]
recruiter knows how tough it is right
now but they've figured out solutions
for the problems you're facing see for
yourself right now you can try them for
free at Zip yeah.com
Zip recruiter is ready to tackle your
recruiting challenges
um
to reach more of the right people
you know it's like we're reaching people
but it's not the right people
I didn't know you could say that in 2023
uh excuse me as a person of color what
do you mean the right people that has
very cryptic message there anyway
the devil Read post your job to 100 I am
a person of color I am Orange
and I don't think I am represented in
the job place your job to 100 plus job
sites need to hire as soon as possible
zip recruit is smart technology finds a
great match matches for your job sooner
want first dibs on Talent zip
lets you invite the most qualified
people to apply
to your job zipper Cruise pricing is
straightforward no surprise costs
team up
with a hiring partner who understands
what you need
um
old zip
recruiter four to five employers who
post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day just go
to this exclusive web address to try zip
for free ziprecruiter.com again that's
ziprecruiter.com spell outbur zip
recruiter
the smartest way to hire
I mean if you guys don't think I have
the best dramatic pause
in the podcast game is the kids say in
the game
um
ag1
I thought this was AGI ag1 for for our
next partner is ag-1
um The Daily foundational nutritional
supplement
that supports whole body health
I could use some of this [__] well I
take a bunch of different things where
you can just mix one scoop of powder and
water once a day
a g one was designed with ease in mind
so you can live healthier and better
without having to complicate your
routine I wish I had some ag1 right now
right before I get on that bicycle
you know my old [__] ass getting on
that seat uh ag-1 replaces your
multivitamin probiotic and More in one
simple drinkable
habit
I just pictured being like Iron Man and
just drinking that [__] thing and put
your suit on and going to work ag-1 is a
foundational nutritional supplement that
delivers comprehensive nutrients to
support whole body Health Science driven
formulation of vitamins probiotics and
Whole Food Source nutrients every scoop
is packed with 75 vitamins minerals
probiotics and whole Source food
ingredients of high quality that gives
you major benefits like gut and mood
support boost in energy I want to
[__] use this [__] and even healthier
looking skin and hair and nails what
would you guys do if I [__] started
taking this [__] and I just showed up
with a lion's mane of Ginger hair
you know
hairdo like Bob Rock like that guy that
owns the [__] hot air balloon
remember that that guy he looked like a
like one of those lion tamer guys one of
them died out in Vegas Siegfried and Roy
was like six free in Roy and he was like
the Andy Gibb of that lion Taman family
you know just sort of the black sheep
you know he wasn't in the Lions he was
straight
he had hot air balloons instead of
[__]
what do they call them big cats ag-1 is
raising the standard for quality and
supplement in the supplement category
ag-1 helps you build your health
Foundation First I want to try this [__]
if you want to take ownership of your
health try ag1 and get a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free ag1
travel packs with your first purchase
this sounds like you know if you [__]
don't want to get sick on the road
you know all these people coughing
on the planes or whatever right go to
drink
ag1.com Bird that's drink ag1.com
and as Angel Salazar would say check it
out all right
Chichi get the yejo if you also played
him he was also in Carlito's Way
stand-up comedy Legend
um all right
let's get to the reads for this week
let's get to the [__] reads what song
is that stuck in my head
it's like one of those Bananarama
[__] badge
or Wilson
remember that
Wilson right well said
what was that song
I did another day
gotta say what I did it even hold on for
just one day that was for anxious white
women anxious white women music
you know like just everything in the of
certain Financial category I'm not
talking about the ones on meth and live
in the middle of Pennsylvania
and come around the corner looking like
like a vampire [__] a zombie I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about you
know just a never-ending supply of brand
new stain-free oven mitts like that
level
insider trading level
white all right recall heard about this
new trucks ain't nothing compared to the
old ones
Ford recalls 870
000 F-150 trucks over unexpected parking
brake activation wait a minute
that guy that I [__] follow start
your engines on YouTube said if you
bought a Ford truck you [__]
and I was just like ah this guy's doing
some chicken little [__]
oh no I bought a f but I bought the 250.
wait a second what is this
um that's no big deal it's just a
[__] parking brake slamming on when
you [__] go in 80 miles an hour
towing a boat what could go wrong
I said Friday it's okay Washington Ford
Motor Company said it Friday it's for
calling 870 000 F-150 trucks in the
United States because the risk of an
unexpected activation of the electric
parking brake due to a potential wiring
issue the recalls covered 2021 through
2023 model F-150 trucks according to a
filing hey I got one for you is anybody
did your directional work well on your
truck and now all of a sudden it goes
like 90 miles an hour when you turn it
on on inside the truck
and then you go outside to see if it's
doing it and giving somebody an
epileptic seizure behind you but it
isn't the tailgate you know the the the
brake light one in the front one is
still going you know like blink Bonk
think dunk like that but inside the cab
it's going
to get like super [__] fast
um
I don't give a [__]
I still lock my Ford truck
um all right well that's good to know
it's good to know that I have that issue
coming up
um but all a recall is is you just bring
it in and they fix it for free
before it ever happens so I mean they're
kind of being responsible no
and I would say because it's electronic
rather than just how it used to be it
just stepped on the thing and it was
like a spring
some sort of police system I have no
idea I'm not mechanically inclined
um the more sophisticated is the more
weight it adds to the vehicle
the more things that can go wrong the
more fuel it burns palm trees
um hey Bill I live in Los Angeles and I
recently heard that palm trees have a
life expectancy of 125 years and most of
them were planted 110 years ago which
will lead to a mass die off of trees in
the next 15 years or so so is this
something your landscapers have warned
you about they have not but I didn't
realize that um I only found out
recently that palm trees are not
indigenous
to uh
to Los Angeles
well listen I think what will happen is
in
areas
that people don't have money
which is becoming everything but the
upper class at this point as we slowly
go into just haves and have-nots and we
destroy the middle class
uh Biden's America I love when they do
that you can thank Donald Trump for that
oh yeah
in [__] four years he did all of that
it's been happening my entire life
regardless of who is in office
it's been a slow March too we get
everything in you you should be lucky
that something trickles down to you
um
all right I live in Los Angeles yeah I
uh I think you know Beverly Hills
they'll they'll just fly in
they'll just go buy some full-side ones
full-size ones and they'll put them in
there
that is amazing
15 years I'll be 70 years old people
that's how fast life goes by
um so right as I'm dying off no I
actually think I'm gonna do all right in
that department we'll see you never know
uh daily Club
uh Billy Twilight toes
I have no idea what that means but I
actually like that even if it's an
insult
I remember Billy White Shoes Johnson
in the NFL
I could have been the white version of
him Billy Twilight toast over the middle
over the middle of Billy Twilight toes
I'll tell you he's the slowest guy in
the league but somehow God bless his
freckled art he figures out a way to get
open all these thought is he understands
the defense he's sitting down in the
zone Oh I thought he just turned around
after they said after they hiked the
ball Billy Twilight toes
has 40 yards receiving
and we're only in the third quarter he
could beat his best record his best game
of 41 yards
um you ever think of joining a country
club or an Elks Club
or would you get sick of seeing the same
people every day
I think you know what back when I was
drinking I thought about doing that
um I'd hate to have to help out with
functions or be on duty for some work so
I think Elks a rotary club might not be
for me country club would be nice if
there was no heavy pressure of high high
school-esque drama between the rich
people
um
I'm more of an Elks Club guy
I like I like
I like that type of stuff
you notice I don't golf
so I feel like that's all they do at
country clubs is everybody goes out and
they golf
oh Jesus and just the sound
you know the sound of golf spikes
on a sidewalk
you know that's the male version of like
stiletto heels
where you just know mail like when you
hear that's like male bimbos
[Laughter]
oh God
with that big fat [__] torsos from
just eating those sandwiches
giant [__] sandwiches they all got
that [__] heart attack body
um all right
AI
Bill my biggest problem with AI is that
it just came out of nowhere right
and I thought they've been working on it
for a while there was no steady on ramp
to having to hear those letters every
[__] day
uh it's like the words streaming content
and algorithm it feels like they were
coming out of the shoot way too fast
into the 22nd century
uh I'm sure I'll be asking my kids how
to use the AI in 15 years the way my old
man asked me about the internet and then
I'll be asking his kid how to do how to
update the software on his robotic
implants thanks and go [__] yourself
um
yeah I don't know why we need AI I think
it all comes down to just
It's a combination
of like
sociopaths at the top
are sick of strikes in workers that have
needs
because they want to take everything so
if they have like robots and that type
of [__] they'll never go on strike
and then but they don't know how to
build them and then but then you have
nerds
who don't know how to talk to women so
the Nerds are smart enough to know what
the sociopaths are doing but the
temptation to actually you know
build a hot chick that will [__] them
you know so they can go to Comic-Con and
have a little [__] Swagger in this
step it's just to it's too it's too
tempting so they go ahead and make them
nerds are the [__] worst nerds make
sociopaths dreams come true
you know sociopaths come up with just
insane [__] right
like can I have a prostitute that's also
a nuclear weapon
and then the Nerds are like well yeah I
mean can I [__] it too
only during the uh the testing phase all
right cool I'll do it
uh Japan
Bill Burr Sensei thanks for all the
laughs for the past decade plus I've
been listening since Let It Go in my
high school days in Pasadena I'm in my
late 20s living in Japan I heard in last
week's episode that it is a bucket list
place for you it's really an amazing
country something that you might
personally find interesting is Japan's
comedy scene which is massive especially
in Osaka what
oh my God I would love to see that the
closest thing that I've seen to stand-up
comedy being performed in Japanese is
when I went to Scotland
because it might as well have been they
might as well have been speaking
Japanese because I couldn't understand a
[__] word these guys were saying it
was amazing
this guy would told this whole [__]
story I couldn't understand any of it
until the his tag
or his punch line was toughen up you
weak hunt that was the only part I
understood
toughen up your weekend
um I once went to an assembly
at my neighborhood middle school and
watched two class leaders perform a
pre-scripted set making fun of relatable
everyday things like popular teacher
like a popular teacher or falling asleep
in class the style is called
man's eye
and it's much different from American
stand-up manzai is fast paced scripted
dialogue and done in Duos
oh my God that's fascinating despite the
language barrier you might be interested
in going to to a show to see just how
different it is and how
and yet how Japanese people go crazy for
it I would love to see that I'm gonna
look it up now
so I don't have to travel and actually
get the experience
no I I um
that's incredible
I would love to see all right lastly I
also know you're a sauna guy and that
you like to support
local businesses you got to experience a
stay at
ryokin
or traditional in for at least one night
you'll sleep on a tatami mat floor with
futon mattress drink complimentary green
tea eat a hearty Japanese breakfast
dress in traditional bathrobes and use
the hot bath dude I'm in
I just can't deal with the flight
don't you have to fly like
I said straight North up to like Santa
Claus with a [__]
Globe isn't as big around the waist and
then you fly over
the best case is to find a royokin in a
hot spring Onsen Village and use that
ryokin's private bath they are allowed
to channel the town's natural hot spring
water to the property
there are too many incredible Onsen
villages to choose from but I'm not I'm
going to butcher all these names
Ryu
chinmura
kinosaki that sounds like a motorcycle
company in takayama
come to mind initially
I can see why people want to learn that
language those are cool names
where do you live takayama
takayama [__] a lot of Shoguns
and samurais used to vacation in these
places so you'll be in good company in
addition to getting hit hard from covid
these beautiful
locally owned small businesses are
losing fashion to Big resort and hotel
chains they're worth every penny to
support God damn these [__]
corporations
sayonara for now ciao for now I get it
sayonara for now oh that was a a cute
little thing I see what you did there
um all right that is the podcast
everyone go [__] yourselves I will check
in on you on Thursday go Red Sox